après plus d'un an de pandémie beaucoup
de jeunes ne vont pas bien privés de
leurs amis et de leur sport plusieurs
adolescents sont en quête de sens le
facteur commun c'est je dirais une
espèce de perte de points de repère
stress anxiété troubles alimentaires
idées suicidaires
certains ont développé de graves
troubles de santé mentale à québec 25
enfants et adolescents avec des
diagnostics d'anorexie ont été
hospitalisés depuis le mois d'août
actuellement on est autour du double des
consultation habituelle et absolument et
qui est ancienne
c'est la pandémie des adolescents à
l'hôpital sainte-justine de montréal
les adolescents hospitalisés pour
troubles alimentaires en 2021
on était quatre fois plus nombreux que
la moyenne des dernières années ce qui
arrive jusqu'à l'hôpital jusqu'au
cabinet du pédiatre même jusqu'à être
hospitalisé il faut bien se rendre
compte que par définition c'est la
pointe de 9
le problème est le même partout au
canada les hôpitaux pour enfants note
deux fois plus d'hospitalisations pour
des tentatives de suicide trois fois
plus pour de l'abus de substances et
pour ceux qui demandent de l'aide
l'attenté longue les délais se compte en
mois et même en années dans le réseau
public les professionnels du québec font
donc front commun ils lancent une
pétition et publie une lettre ouverte
pour demander au gouvernement d'agir
rapidement
mais vu de la nette si vraiment on veut
que tout soit fait pour améliorer
l'accessibilité à des soins vraiment
spécialisés pour traiter les problèmes
sentimentaux
pour y parvenir il faudra bonifier les
salaires selon elle les psychologues du
réseau public québécois accuse un écart
de salaire de près de 30 $ de l'heure
avec leurs homologues de l'ontario rien
pour séduire les doctorants et atteint 1
25% qui vient à raison du travail pour
que la santé mentale des jeunes
s'améliore il faudra que tous mettent la
main à la partie est le principe qui dit
pour ce qui fait d'un enfant ça prend un
village le sait vraiment ce actuellement
dc cam et carpentier radio canada lévy